happy holidays it's the official
gift-giving season of the year if you
think kids need Santa Claus think of all
the adults out there who are about to
live off ramen for the next six months
just so that they can pay for all those
gifts thankfully I've come up with a
cheaper tastier and more thoughtful
approach to gift-giving this season
check out my top 3 DIY holiday gifts for
the foodies on your list first up my
sweet and spicy almonds in a medium bowl
I whisk together an egg white and water
until frothy and mix with some blanched
almonds in another bowl I combined some
brown sugar and yummy spices and toss
the almonds in until they're coated well
spread the almond mixture onto a
prepared baking sheet in an even layer
and sprinkle with fleur de sel then
place in the oven and bake for 25 to 30
minutes at 300 degrees stirring at least
halfway room when it's time to gift add
a personal touch with one of these cute
name tags then take a recycled nut
container remove the label and cover it
with festive paper then insert a
cellophane bag and fill it with your
spiced nuts finish with some pretty
ribbon and enjoy next my orange rosemary
olives in a small saucepan I heat some
olive oil with garlic some strips of
orange zest grated orange zest and a
whole rosemary sprig over medium heat
for 5 minutes then I pour the olive oil
mixture over some mixed olives and pack
it into a glass jar top the lid with
some holiday paper and something fun
like this pine cone I found on the side
of the road wrap in some pretty ribbon
and fasten with some olive forks for
easy access and finally my four seasons
chocolate bark pour some melted dark
chocolate into a baking sheet lined with
a nonstick nap then get creative I
couldn't decide so I made for different
flavor combos one corner I added minced
ginger cranberries gingersnaps and
pistachios on the other I did candy
canes and white chocolate drizzle then I
did freeze dried fruit almonds pink
peppercorns and some salt and finally
some golden raisins sesame seeds pine
and candied lemon to gift-wrap I add
some pretty ribbon and fasten a bow
along with a crab mallet to smash your
chocolate bark these gifts are so
delicious easy and inexpensive to pull
off you'll have enough for both your
nice and naughty list happy holidays
guys from my kitchen to yours we're
great healthy holiday ideas be sure to
subscribe to my channel and I'll see you
next time Abby station